hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com slash the
minimalists enjoy
[Music]
hi
hello hi
so what's your name oh morgan my name is
morgan hey morgan what's on your mind
so many things but i'll try to limit it
um so
i agree that
we try to avoid the conversation of
grief
even more so than the conversation of
death
and recently i've had three friends just
totally leave my life for very various
reasons
um a sibling also same case
in all of those there was
uh
moving because their family wouldn't let
them talk to me leaving my life because
they have drug addictions leaving my
life because of this that and the other
and
um
how how do you
what do you say to somebody who already
has a hard time making human connections
um
to to help them understand how how to
find value in people
without using them like i
am missing these amazing people in my
life
and maybe i just want somebody to go
with hiking with maybe i just want
somebody to go out to coffee with or
something like that but i don't want to
use people it sounds like you're afraid
that you you you're afraid that these
relationships could become transactional
in some way exactly well let's talk
about what it means to love i think we
can start there
um we get really confused about love
i love my wife
but i love burritos
in canada up in the the nunavut region
they uh the the inuits have a dial one
of their dialects they have 53 different
words to describe snow
we have one word to describe what we
call love
and we still don't know what the hell it
means
right one is like if i say i love
burritos i what i'm really saying is i
really like it that's what that means
right
or if i love my pickup truck
fine but i really like that thing right
or maybe it adds immense value to my
life that's what i'm saying about that
we're using that same word if i say i
love my wife that's something different
right now most of us when we say i love
someone it means i'm attached to them
well that's also not love attachment
blocks love
and so what is love to love someone is
to see them for who they are without
trying to change them
right and so if you can show up with
someone else
and see them
for who they are without convincing
coercing persuading
debating
all those things are unloving as well to
convince someone is to unlove them
right but if you can show up and see
them for who they are
well then you aren't using them
at all
joanna also i'd like to talk to you
about something here because this is
triggering a thought in my mind
often people
they have to grieve the relationship
they wish they had because for a long
time was like oh yeah i love you as long
as you do these seven things in this
order by this date
then um i have my conditional love for
you but of course conditional love it's
an oxymoron
you
i'm sure you can talk more eloquently
about this than i can but but
understanding that oh you know what i
want that relationship to be this way
but it's never going to be
this way we might have to sort of grieve
that as well
is that fair uh sure it's fair or you i
just continue to suffer
right because if your expectation of the
other capital o is here
and all they have to give is here
then then it's going to be a very tense
and frustrating relationship
and we can only change ourselves we
can't change other people we can only
change how we respond and interact with
others right so yeah i guess in a way
you either have to surrender to
um yeah i'm i'm just gonna
if this is where they can meet me then
i'm gonna have to if i want to continue
this relationship i'm gonna i'm gonna
meet them here
or you will end up being very frustrated
for a long time and adding a lot of
suffering to your plate and the irony of
that is it's always someone else who's
frustrating me right
at least that's in my mind that's how it
works i can't believe ryan was doing
that
on the way to the venue today
and
it's a real sign of maturity too
in fact i think it's the main sign of
maturity to stop blaming other people
realizing oh
ryan didn't make me upset i
made me upset oh but his behavior made
me upset well maybe i don't like his
behavior but that's just because i had
an expectation that his behavior would
be something else
right and so in a way i might even have
to grieve my own sort of expectations or
i can cling to it
and then i can get dragged by whatever
i'm clinging to
yeah
yeah i mean if i was at anything i would
just say with any relationship to make
sure you're not
just taking uh you bring as much as you
can to the relationship and let's say
the other person is taking from you um
because i have relatives who
uh i a i got a brother i got two
brothers who had some very bad drug
problems and they were like hitting me
up for money a lot of the times and
sometimes i'd help him out like if i had
it i would help him out but then it gets
to a certain point where i'm like okay i
have to set a boundary with you
so that i'm not just
exhausting my resources on something
that is really just kind of enabling
them to do you know bad things
and uh again approaching it with
compassion i was very
very much able to set those boundaries
and i've got i've got pretty good
relationships with my my brothers i mean
i have a brother in prison right now but
i talk to him on a regular basis
um and uh he stopped asking me for money
and now now we can just have a you know
normal conversation
um but yeah i mean it's it's uh it's
it's it's a tough thing to do sometimes
but again like just like like i said the
last time approaching it with compassion
to set those boundaries
is is totally appropriate
to to set boundaries is to love by the
way because if you're just saying yes
all the time that's not loving that's
just
yeah placating exactly so to set
boundaries is living
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free